guys this this next story is is pitiful
ever since the holiday shooting there's
been a spike
uh in the discussions rightfully so
about gun control and
that means many more republicans than
usual are going to have to be asked why
they stand in the way of any common
sense gun reform
and shockingly enough a host on fox news
actually asks senator mike lee a really
good question
and she shows polling on the support for
a number of these big
main common-sense gun reforms that
people push for and shows just how
wildly popular they are and then asks
senator mike lee
aren't you out of step with your
constituents if these
items these proposals are this popular
let's look at how he responds strength
behind some of these proposals
at this point some of these proposals
background checks for guns which by and
large most of them are
background checked before you do a
purchase 88 percent though moving the
legal age for an assault rifle purchase
is at 82
flagging for people uh who are danger to
themselves or others those red flag laws
81 percent and banning assault weapons
63 percent
there is a lot of momentum at least
among the public sphere for doing this
are you out of step with your
constituents
okay so first of all what's important is
that we look out for the rights of
constituents constituents are asked poll
questions they're not asked questions
about specific language within
legislative texts it's the job of the
lawmaker to look out for the interests
and the rights of the law abiding
citizens they represent and so with each
of those provisions i understand how
they could get high popularity readings
when they don't define them for example
you talk about banning assault weapons
there there is no universal definition
of what an assault rifle is very often
the true distinction
it really depends on whether the stock
pieces of the gun are made of wood or of
plastic or of composite
um
and so
that the text does matter here uh
because it's that text that will
determine uh whether we're intruding
unduly on the rights of the americans
the american law-abiding citizen
and doing so in a way that would
actually deter violent criminal behavior
so first off even though this is not
something we should have to do
journalists should always be this way i
want to thank the fox news host for
actually asking a real question
and i just want to make sure you guys
don't get at all misled about this
because i think we have a tendency when
someone's on television and they
finish a complete sentence and then look
at the camera confidently we go oh dang
they successfully dodged the question
but no that entire clip he said a lot of
words
with zero substance
he goes on and on about the text of the
bill the text of the bill yes that's
your job you're a legislator
your job is to take general proposals
that are popular in the country and then
are popular among your constituents at
least
and then implement them and
throughout that process you work out the
specifics of the bill you work out the
details that you are referring to as the
text of the bill
we all recognize that universal
background checks is a little bit more
complicated than just writing down on a
bill universal background checks
go right we understand that you don't
need to say that to us
but you as sure as hell should not be
using it as an excuse for not acting on
the issue um there's a lot of specifics
that we don't know about yet well get
working buddy
his answer of course should have been i
absolutely support those proposals you
just put on screen as you mentioned they
are both popular and they would save
lives and they don't infringe on our
rights
all i want to do now is work on the the
nuts and bolts of this legislation
and then we'll be able to accomplish the
goals set out by those more general
positions that you just outlined but
instead he gives the weakest and laziest
answer to get out of genuinely answering
why he doesn't support the reforms that
would save lives as i mentioned and
would be in line with his own
constituents
he didn't even answer her specific
question
really which was are you out of line
with your constituents yes is the answer
to that question
he said effectively oh well the reason
is his constituents aren't able to look
out for their own rights
that's his job well no your constituents
understand by that polling that
it's not an infringement on their right
to regulate uh firearms in a common
sense way
and i honestly don't know how people
like mike lee feel good about themselves
after giving an answer that's that slimy
and that dishonest
you gave that answer to protect the gun
lobby and this delusional idea that any
form of regulation
and trying to implement any common sense
gun reform
is revoking the second amendment or
something
and i know this sometimes comes off as a
little bit hyperbolic but honestly how
do people like mike lee live with
themselves knowing all of these
tragedies are going to happen in the
future or the not all of them but a
number of tragedies are going to happen
in the future because we didn't act now
and he's one of the people standing in
the way giving dishonest answers like
that
to
for really no good reason and it's going
to cause these tragedies and i really
don't know how people like him
live with will live with themselves